dare to did it add a derp derp derp derp
dee doo doo doot doot doot I'll call the
forest got updated uh-huh a new AI
uh-huh you female enemy alright added
procured oral breast sight system let's
play it never in my life have I been
this excited for a video game whoa
alright we're back and I get to keep my
house that's a my where's my
[ __ ] FEG where's all my [ __ ]
now Lizzie Lizzie you turn into us would
know what they Laci
listen you try to trick me come back
here
don't think I didn't see you without
what's up here sorry I was just oh god I
gotta go what all right Lizzie I need
you come out now pets up your cries I
does it crazy person skinned people
alive whoa nice light nice butt twerk
Lizzie I'm proud of you alright let's
wear Lizzie Lizzie is the highest
standard of fashion all right we need to
we need to cook some food anyway the
game looks a lot different and I don't
think it looks better to be honest so
the real question now is if we can build
something new supposedly you can now
build the wood bench so let's start off
by doing that and we can watch the
sunset together let's put it right in
front of our little [ __ ] there I love
this game especially when it gets
updated it's all good in the hood let's
cut out a tree I'm a lumberjack oh I'm
moku I sleep all night and I work all
day alright let's try this bench
Oh Lizzie you've joined me to sit on the
bench with me no I don't want to sit
with you ah shut up and sit there we go
that's what you get
alright let's try this out Lizzie
I love you Lacey you know that right
that's of course pants
let's sit amazing this is my new
favorite bench
isn't that right Lizzie hey that's
that's great Lizzie a guy was that
Lizzie hold me oh I can't [ __ ] hear
you Lizzie talk normally please
oh man isn't the nature just wonderful
thing especially physics
I [ __ ] love physic Lizzie oh man that
was a great set let's try that again
nope
I keep setting like that how do I sit
huh how did they miss you stop ah ha ha
go in the water Lizzie I'm dying oh
thank god finally what what did you say
I mean nothing I love you that's right
you better kiss me [ __ ] all right one
more try
sit on the bench one more try Wow
saw done all right well my guy is really
mentally not stable so oh you burned my
lousy armor it burned it all come on
isn't that right Lizzie I would
appreciate if you stopped kissing me I'm
gonna pretend I didn't [ __ ] hear what
else do they update can we actually
build a houseboat now that'd be great
I don't think we can let's try it out no
it doesn't look like it which is
probably a good thing cuz the [ __ ]
cabin it took me three years to build
well I think it's time for you and me
Lizzie to kill some people and make them
into effigies all right I see some
people over there what do they want
let's stay away for now I want to see
their girls
oh god I think they see me bird you you
tweeted didn't you you [ __ ] well that's
fine because I have arm and arm is the
destroyer of worlds
hi I'm out of here oh god oh god
ha are you the new girl can I see you
sorry it's too dark let's go here let's
go here come here
there we go let's see those Tatas oh
come on don't be shy
ow that's sexist while I'm holding an
arm so it's okay oh god stop it don't
make me slap you stupid do you want me
to slap you
hey hey hey hey I'm wearing Lizzy armor
calm the [ __ ] down I'll slap you
that's right let's forget for
disrespecting me don't disrespect
you're all my batches you're all my
batches isn't that right lacy lens day
answer me
Lizzy don't make me slap you that's
right let's flap that booty that's a
great police line so I'm so hand
stop it hand you're being sexist hand
see slap them into it so they'll they'll
won't make a tumblr post he has a fine
boot he had to find a booty he has to
find what if you only would let me slap
your booty please there we go see now
now what the heat is going lazy where
you going I'll follow you Lizzy
follow me heads I'll follow you up to
soccer all right I think we might it at
a lab let's fist Lizzy I think they have
something out for your arm I think they
don't like you
or was it hand yeah I was hand you
really do come in handy why aren't you
laughing do you want me to tickle your
belly or some [ __ ] new battle plan this
time we attack them but we actually kill
them because I want to build that
[ __ ] air for G what are you
doing what are you doing ground stop it
Berry's dead I kill your your friend any
last web needed thinks oh I got his butt
I got your prints but I'll sell that on
eBay you can buy it back if you want to
like what your boyfriend is doing haha
where's he going he's like nope look at
your boyfriend now oye oye that's what
you get for [ __ ] with me let's lift
this up it's so dark here Jesus
oh there's much legs and [ __ ] how he
dropped a lot of legs he probably was
pretty alright well let's build some
effigies how do we do it now again
beautiful APG beautifully apt beer
better [ __ ] mg how many hands today ah
ah what are you doing oh god they're
here in my house in my house in my house
oh god it's locked shut alright nan ba
ba ba blonde bear come on back
alright it's gonna be fine hey si si I
need you now oh god they're cray-cray
baby quickly I need to get in I need to
get [ __ ] in in my house don't touch
me don't touch me I'll poke you come
near come come and poking race range I
dare you
that's right that's what happens come
here come for another poke please you
like pokes this is like the Battle of
Midgard except not really at all all
right this has gone on for far too young
eating it ow ow ow that really hurts
that really really [ __ ] hurts
you guys don't [ __ ] insane take it
that's right
oh god what is happening out then
Molotov is heat-seeking ow
I'm gonna fire this girl is on fire oh
man this episode is so intense I'll have
to drink a soda
excellent all right are they dead are
they dead yeah she's dead hello
you okay that's great hello you okay
that's great all right so I'm gonna call
you my you guys are gonna be my like my
new pets
that's okay I'll call you Gandalf and
your name okay um I'll call you the
Biebs
Gandalf Pheebs and Sally Oh God sally
has friends I'm gonna poke her Oh
oh god oh god the hand of doom it's so
powerful oh my god oh my god the power
of the hand oh I am not worthy hand I am
not worthy Lizzie
Oh Lizzie what are you doing on my
screen what the [ __ ] how dare you Pierce
I'm sorry I'm so sorry I'm so sorry
sorry Liz you have to die I'm hungry and
what are you doing what I tell you about
break dancing stop it stop it silly
silly silly hand oh my god what a day
what a [ __ ] day it's been a long
night
let's cook some Lizzie tonight I can't
put
Eve Justin just got smothered by the
hand of justice that's what happens man
it's too powerful good thing you're
still here Gandalf let me touch your
beautiful face oh I love you so much
see see you have passed the test the
hand has blessed the eye of the non
death the gods have spoken
Oh God see the hand has released you
from thy curse Oh God
you ungrateful son of a [ __ ] how dare
you defy thy hand you are the chosen one
all right well Gandalf will now serve as
my stairs or his butt will serve as my
stairs let's see if you test passed the
test of hand god o mighty hand Lords we
asked him how to put down thy poor your
porn and and and please show mercy on
what's your name again Sally on Sally
soul will sadly live or Sally die I
leave it to your hands oh the hand gods
have spoken
Sally was not worthy maybe one day we'll
find the chosen one the ultimate hand
master who could do the hand job better
than no one else hmm
but today is not that day the gods are
angry tonight the hand jobs I mean hand
gods are angry tonight it's been a long
day but now we go back to sleep all
right press I'm gonna have to end that
episode there but if you enjoyed
watching go ahead and leave in like
thank you very much for doing so and
thank you for leaving a comment about
the hand jobs hand guides why it's it's
so hard we experienced a lot of [ __ ]
today and it was a lot of fun I love
this game mainly because it's not done
yet that just makes it even funnier and
yeah that's it thanks for watching stay
awesome